vamos con el problema número 6 número 6
y estamos en la página 278 de este
manual del gym
el problema número 6 dice lo siguiente
dice en la figura de arriba las líneas
kahiem son paralelas sería bueno tener
el dibujo verdad el dibujo es más o
menos así son dos rectas tenemos una
transversal nos dicen que esta recta es
la recta acá esta es la recta m
y además nos marcan algunos ángulos este
es de equis grados este de acá es de
grados y este de acá es de zeta grados z
grados ahora sí déjame leer el problema
dice en esta figura las rectas k y m son
paralelas acá es paralela a m y lo que
necesitamos hacer es determinar el valor
de x entonces nos preguntan por el valor
de x vale vale entonces la información
posible que nos dan es 1-1 igual a 120
ya igual a 120 será esto suficiente para
determinar el valor de x pues vamos a
ver si ya es igual a 120 entonces este
ángulo de acá de 120
voy a poner con el mismo color que puse
esta información
entonces si este ángulo es de 120
sabemos que z es de 60 porque jay-z son
suplementarios suman 180 grados porque
forman una línea si esto te suena muy
extraño o no has visto este tipo de
argumentos a lo mejor deberías checar la
lista de geometría ahí platicamos mucho
de paralelas y transversales pero bueno
como ya hice estás son suplementarios
este es de 120 y este es de 120 entonces
z es de 60 grados y ahora como z y x son
alternos internos en estas paralelas con
esta transversal tenemos que x es de 60
grados
vale entonces esta información la del
inciso 1 es suficiente por sí misma para
determinar el valor de x pudimos haberlo
hecho de otra forma o sea como éste ya
es de 120 grados este de acá es
suplementario y entonces mide 60 grados
y ahora x es correspondiente a este de
acá y por lo tanto miden lo mismo vale
son ángulos congruentes y entonces x es
de 60 grados pero bueno el chiste es que
la información uno por sí misma si nos
permite determinar el valor de x vamos a
ver qué sucede con la información 2 con
la información dos lados nos dice que z
es igual a 60 entonces sí z es igual a
60 tenemos que este ángulo es de 60
grados y entonces básicamente nos están
dando la misma información que en el
inciso 1 sí o sea si éste es de 60
grados ahora este de acá lo podemos
determinar es de 120 grados otra vez
porque estos dos son suplementarios y
entonces volvemos a la información de
que es igual a 120 sin que nos lo
hubieran dado o sea sabiendo que 760
podemos concluir que es 120 y podemos
hacer lo mismo de hecho es mucho más
rápido
si se está y es de 60 grados entonces
inmediatamente x es de 60 grados porque
son ángulos alternos internos en
paralelas pero bueno el chiste es que
este pedazo de información el del inciso
2 por sí mismo también es suficiente y
entonces la respuesta es de cada uno de
los incisos por sí mismo es suficiente
para responder la pregunta vamos al
problema número 7 en el problema número
7 nos piden determinar el porcentaje de
mujeres pelirrojas en un grupo entonces
le voy a poner porcentaje de mujeres
pelirrojas
lynn y rojas rojas en un grupo
un grupo muy bien y la información o los
candidatos de información que nos dan es
11 de las mujeres del grupo 5% son
pelirrojas entonces vamos a ponerlo así
5 por ciento de las mujeres o sea de las
mujeres no del total del grupo si no de
las mujeres son pelirrojas
y rojas esto será suficiente para
determinar el porcentaje de mujeres
pelirrojas en el grupo pues yo digo que
no porque puede haber hombres pues ya
puede haber una cantidad muy diferente
de hombres puede ser que haya
simplemente diez hombres o cien hombres
puede haber un millón de hombres y
entonces saber que 5% de las mujeres son
pelirrojas no nos dice nada de la
proporción de mujeres pelirrojas con
respecto a todo el grupo vale bueno
entonces ésta de aquí por sí misma no es
suficiente no es suficiente vamos a ver
qué nos dice el inciso 2 y el inciso 2
nos dice que que el 10 por ciento de los
hombres de los hombres son pelirrojos
son pelirrojos pelirrojos bah pues yo
digo que esto de aquí tampoco sirve y ni
siquiera a juntar las dos informaciones
es suficiente porque porque una vez más
saber que el 10 por ciento de los
hombres son pelirrojos pues sólo nos
dice algo con respecto al porcentaje de
hombres pero no nos dice cómo son las
mujeres con respecto a los hombres en
tamaño una vez más podríamos tener diez
hombres o un millón de hombres y bueno
estas dos cosas podrían ser
o podría ser una información que nos dan
pero ni siquiera juntando ambas podemos
determinar
cuál es el porcentaje de mujeres
pelirrojas en el grupo
en total vale entonces este de acá
tampoco es suficiente y de hecho los dos
juntos no son suficientes
es más déjame hacer un diagrama de ven
yo creo que eso nos ayudaría mucho para
entender un poco un poco más qué sucede
vamos a hacer por aquí un rectángulo un
rectángulo y vamos a dividirlo en dos
vale vamos a dividirlo por ahí más o
menos en dos entonces
imaginemos que de este lado tenemos a
las mujeres y de este lado tenemos a los
hombres vale lo que nos dice este pedazo
de información que 5% de las mujeres son
pelirrojas es simplemente que aquí hay
un cachito que equivale al 5% verdad de
mujeres que son pelirrojas entonces este
cachito de mujeres son pelirrojas pero
eso todavía no nos dice que el
porcentaje del total son mujeres
pelirrojas porque esto podría ser muy
grande de manera similar el inciso 2 nos
dice que un cachito por acá de hombres
que es el 10% son pelirrojos
vale con un cachito de acá son
pelirrojos
pero ni siquiera contando esta
información con esta podemos saber cómo
es esto con respecto al total vale
porque no sabemos cómo es mujeres con
respecto a hombres bueno espero que esto
aclare un poquito más la idea entonces
la respuesta aquí sería eh
ni siquiera juntando ambos enunciados
podemos resolver la pregunta muy bien
vamos al problema número ocho problema
número 8 dice cierre y ese son enteros
positivos entonces r s son enteros
positivos
positivos o sea que el porcentaje es de
ese gen lo que nos preguntan entonces r
qué porcentaje qué porcentaje porcentaje
es de ese básicamente lo que nos están
preguntando es determinar r / s verdad r
entre ellas y sabemos cuánto s r entre s
podemos saber qué porcentaje es r de s
bueno las posibilidades de información
son inciso 1 inciso 1 r es igual a tres
cuartos tres cuartos de s con esta
información podremos determinar r entre
s pues claro que sí sí sí sabemos que
eres igual a tres cuartos de s pasando s
dividiendo que podemos hacer porque no
es cero es un entero positivo tenemos
que r entre s es igual a tres cuartos a
tres cuartos vale entonces aquí pues ya
podemos determinar r entre s esta
información es suficiente y el inciso 2
nos dice hizo 2 nos dice que r ahad
mieres está chistoso nos dice que r
entre s pero escrito así como con el
símbolo de primaria r entre s es igual a
75 entre 100 y por supuesto si r entre
ese 75 entre 100 entonces r entre ese
escrito así es 75
75 sobre 100 vale entonces está de esta
información de aquí abajo por sí misma
también nos permite determinar el
porcentaje o bueno qué porcentaje es ese
ere con respecto a ese vale entonces la
respuesta es de cualquiera de las dos
sirve para responder la pregunta vamos
al problema número nueve el problema
número nueve dice lo siguiente nos
preguntan determinar si es cierto si es
cierto que le gana a ve que le gana a ve
el inciso 1 de información nos dice que
2 es mayor que 2 b estoy aquí será
suficiente para responder lo de aquí
arriba bueno pues simplemente tenemos
que determinar o más bien que recordar
nuestras reglas para manipular
desigualdades y se comportan casi igual
que las igualdades simplemente hay que
recordar que cuando multiplicamos o
dividimos ambos lados de la desigualdad
por un número negativo entonces se
cambia de signo eso no es algo que haya
que tengamos que recordar a fuerza pero
bueno podemos probarlo podemos intentar
casos pequeños para recordarlo
bueno con eso en mente aquí podemos
cancelar el 2 o bien dividir entre 2
ambos lados sin ningún problema y eso
nos permite que nos permite determinar o
nos permite concluir que a le gana a b
vale y entonces pues si podemos
responder esta pregunta entonces este
inciso por sí mismo es suficiente y el
inciso número 2 el inciso número 2 nos
dice que a más a más
c es mayor que p más
bmc y la pregunta es esto nos nos
permitirá determinar que alegan a ave
bueno pues aquí podemos restar se de
ambos lados sin ningún problema aquí
estamos de este lado y de este lado no
se cambia la desigualdad porque estamos
simplemente restando de ambos lados y
entonces nos queda que a es mayor que ve
a es mayor que b y por lo tanto por lo
tanto podemos concluir que el 2 nos
permite responder la pregunta vale
entonces cualquiera de estos dos nos
permite resolver o determinar si ya es
mayor que b y por lo tanto la respuesta
es b
vamos a seguirle en el siguiente vídeo